hating Breitbart the late Andrew
Breitbart is known for his suite of big
websites like the government big
Hollywood big journalism big piece and
he's also known for his role in the
controversy that led to the
congressional defunding of acorn and the
resignation of New York Congressman
Anthony Weiner so thanks so much for
joining us thanks for having me
did you know Andrew Breitbart well I did
over the course of tuna three years
don't mean him I came to know him very
well
and how did the documentary come to be I
was on the ground covering Tea Party
protests protests even before that but
it didn't take long covering Tea Party
protests before my path crossed with
Andrew Breitbart Andrew Breitbart
uniquely personified the fight that the
tea party movement was going through at
the time yeah when they first launched
they were accused of being racist
potentially violent and at that exact
moment Andrew Breitbart was launching
his acorn tapes and was being accused of
the exact same thing he's been accused
of being racist and Andrew Breitbart
sort of found a home a synergy inside
the Tea Party because of that I was very
interested in telling the story of what
I was seeing going on the Tea Party but
Andrew Breitbart really personified that
yeah I found a real common belief set
there with him I discovered my own
frustration with the media I went to
Crawford Texas for the Cindy Sheehan
protests and I saw the difference
between what I witnessed on the ground
there and what the media was portraying
that was really sort of the birth of my
outrage at the media because of that so
by the time I came across the end
Rubright part I think there was just
sort of we clicked naturally because of
that and he had an interesting way of
categorizing his own political beliefs
in the documentary he said that he was a
conservative but sympathetic to the
libertarian movement and
necessarily a social conservative so it
doesn't really make him a libertarian
you know I I would think of most circles
yeah he probably would be considered
libertarian for that um but he
definitely I think he's what you would
call I'm gonna quote Dave Massey of USA
Today he says who referred described it
as being a creature of the right and I
think that's what he was he was of the
right and I think that you know like
most people in this country he was
center-right so I would think on some
things he would definitely he would have
self-identified as libertarian but but I
think he was probably also a fiscal
conservative and I think on foreign
policy he was probably more conservative
and libertarian so he was a mix he was a
mix and in 2004 he told reason that he
was actually a political and that he
Matt Welch described him as having no
political philosophy whatsoever would
you agree that I don't think he was
intentionally political I mean I think
he had a huge effect politically so
whether he wanted to be or not he was
political but his motivation was
definitely not political his motivation
you know here's a guy who I call him the
perfect storm because he came of age as
a as a contributor to The Drudge Report
he was behind the scenes when the Monica
Lewinsky scandal happened okay and was
that was that the defining moment for
drugs
oh I don't know I'm not sure I'm sure in
terms of drug I don't know he's kind of
a black box he sort of you don't know
how to read what what what he what his
perspective is but it was definitely for
Andrew you know for Andrew I think that
he looked at the at the Lewinsky scandal
as a story about the chief executive
line under oath okay and then he watched
the mainstream media craft this
narrative that it was all about the sex
and that anybody who was interested in
this story is only interested in because
of the sex and they're uptight Puritans
or perverts or whatever and I think he
was horrified by that and so it really
was what he witnessed in the
eeeh that drove him his whole passion
but he used to say politics is
downstream from culture and he believed
that the politics was almost irrelevant
if you're losing the culture fight
you're done you're toast and so while he
may have had desires politically in
terms of trying to affect politics I
think he saw the source of it as culture
and so he was a culture warrior instead
of a political warrior and what part did
he have in breaking and making the
Lewinsky scandal such a huge story like
Andrew specifically do you know I don't
know yeah I don't know the details of it
actually so in the filming of the
documentary there were only two no-go
zones and one of the no-go zones was the
Drudge Report and his work with the Drug
Report because Matt Drudge was extremely
protective of his brand of course you
should be and so nobody anybody keep
there are people out there that work on
the Drudge Report that you would never
know because they're just they never
ever talk about it so that was one thing
it was a no-go zone we couldn't talk
about the drug that was actually one of
the questions I had about the
documentary I'm really interested in
that part of his past I was you know
what part of his history with Matt
Drudge made the Andrew Breitbart that we
all knew and did they have a close
relationship were they friendly what was
the status of their relationship when he
died oh I think it was friendly banter
edge came to his funeral I mean I think
that's the biggest testament to how matt
drudge felt the body under Breitbart so
I do believe that they were close on
that level no because again it was it
was you know again like I said there
were two no-go zones the other one was
Andrew his wife and children which
prevented us from making this film you
know like a typical biography and had to
be more about his work and his mission
and the fight that he was fighting
because of that so no we didn't pursue
it because we didn't want to alienate
Andrew you know do anything to you know
disturb whatever Andrew was doing
because that would be the documentary
dramatically affecting our subjects yeah
he talked about Arianna Huffington
certainly and he was always very proud
that he was a part of launching that
site because again he didn't consider
himself an ideologue and he always used
to say more voices not less and so I
think he felt like his work with Arianna
is speaking to that part of himself now
I think he was very frustrated with with
what happened at that huffington post
because he ended up quickly leaving
because he I think he felt there there
while Huffington Post represented
bringing more voices to the macro
dialogue in the micro and Huffington
Post I don't think he felt like there
was any room for any diversity of
thought there well but then it would
have been all about her I think she was
just being nice because this might have
been the first moment where everyone
stopped and went because right calm
sounds like boy Duras calm it sounds
like something that might have been
around for a long time people who didn't
know of Andrew Breitbart as the
personality might not know that and this
was really the first time that people
stopped and said wait a second who is
this guy what is going on here you know
I think Andrew was always planning on
coming out publicly and again with the
drug report he could have tremendous
influence but none of it publicly
you know people began to see the
Breitbart brand because he was able to
link from the drug report to Breitbart
calm but you're right nobody nobody knew
who he was nobody he wasn't on anybody's
radar until the acorn story happened and
I think that you know and again you know
for most people
Andrew Breitbart was an overnight
phenomenon you know but for Andrew
Breitbart
that was a pretty consistent line he
again he was informed by his outrage at
what he saw is a fundamental unfairness
in the media and so his whole take on
the Acorn story his hope his whole Drive
for it was even sort of less about what
was happening at ACORN and more about
the media and that's why he staggered
the video releases the way that he did
because his goal I think was not
necessarily to take down acorn it was to
expose the mainstream media in the
process and acorn was defunded in the
process and and it was it was really
brilliant and it worked well for him
in this story because he was able to put
out a video and Bertha Lewis and you
know lawmaker allies came out and said
well it didn't happen here they were
kicked out there and then all of a
sudden more and more videos came out
it's the first time that he could think
of in memory where a we're such an
important policy decision was made to
defund this organization without a
column inch being written in the New
York Times or The Washington Post the
first time they've reported on the story
was it's aftermath you know so they had
their readers had to be had to have been
wondering we'll wait wait how did how
did all this happen
and while they're reporting on it
they're attacking James O'Keefe for not
being a big jnf journalist absolutely
well and this is what they did and this
was what we witnessed and it's part of
what led us to to go along the theme of
hating the hating Breitbart and it's
really not just about hating Breitbart
it's about hating it's a machine of
hatred that's in place frankly that is
aimed at anyone who is not sufficiently
progressive enough and what they do is
they they try to attach a meme to you a
label some kind of some kind of idea
that gets hooked to you so that no
matter what you do going forward they
can recall that so in the case of acorn
they latched on to this notion that
James O'Keefe lied about dressing as a
pimp going into these offices because at
the beginning of the acorn videos he
does a sort of a boor odd kind of MTV
opening you know where he's dressed in
the in a flamboyant outfit now when you
watch the videos you can see in the
first 16 seconds in the first video when
he's walking into the office of his hand
goes in the frame and you see he's not
wearing that he's dressed as as he
presented himself as a somebody who
wanted to run for Congress and was
looking to launder the money from
underage prostitutes for his
congressional campaign my guess is that
he told them he was gonna run it as a
Republican they wouldn't have helped him
launder the money because he was gonna
run as a true progressive they were
willing to help him you know so what
would they try to do is attach this meme
to him that he's a liar that he
selectively edited and they tried to
attach that to Andrew Breitbart as well
he's he's dishonest he selectively edits
and and the reason that they tried news
outlet doesn't select right well that
was part of what made him so furious was
the very people that work using them of
this make and it's all the time you know
in any news program on NBC well not only
get they went even further they released
all of the audio transcripts of all of
the and all of the audio recordings
themselves of the raw material now
nobody does that
and even in doing that they were accused
of selectively editing and
misrepresenting that that's what you
know look what happened they they
launched the Acorn tapes a corn gets
defunded and investigations happen in
the investigations are not indeed corn
they were into James Hannah and Andrew
Breitbart now was he accused of being
racist in the Acorn scandal the way he
was with Shirley Sherrod yes not as much
where Shirley Sherrod was off the charts
in terms of the racism charge but yes
and that was the beginning of the charge
of racism for him and the narrative went
like this acorn helps black people so if
you're against acorn you're against
black people your motive is probably
that you're against black people and
that was the that was the racism charged
that launched and they did a smear job
on James O'Keefe he had attended a
conference where it was a some I think
it was a white supremacist debating a
black guy and and because of that they
determined it was a white supremacist
conference and the James O'Keefe was the
organizer and they smeared him with it
for simply attending you know these are
the people who who were for years have
held up the specter of McCarthyism and
guilt by association and they were
willing to completely associate James
O'Keefe with white supremacism simply
because he was in the same room with
somebody now the slow roll out with
Shirley Sherrod didn't work as well for
Andrew Breitbart yes because that really
was a piece of the speech that was
abstracted obviously he's not gonna
release a 45-minute speech but that did
not bode well for him that blew up in
his face was that his greatest misstep
what's that narrative certainly didn't
work the way he had intended that's for
sure but I'm not even so sure that it
was his misstep look there's a correct
on their website and anybody can go see
their correction and their correction
was specific to you know when the story
she was telling you know when that was
reference the period of time that was
referencing okay so now that was a
legitimate error that they made and I
think it's pretty common it's a common
error in journalism you know you don't
want to have that but that's what
Corrections are for and that's you know
why people issue them what they jumped
on though the way that they attacked him
he was for something that he did not do
what they what they attacked him for was
misrepresenting her in terms of the fact
that she ended up helping the white
farmer and that was what you you know if
you if you look back at the news clip so
you look back at all their coverage they
immediately got the farmer on the on the
television and had her with in the
side-by-side with the farmer and farmer
saying oh yeah she absolutely helped us
in the narrative became a hundred
Breitbart lied about all of this but if
you read Andrew Breitbart Speas and if
you watch the video he put up even in
the video he put up Shirley Sherrod says
I eventually helped the white farmer and
Andrew Breitbart and his piece rights
her humanity led her to help the white
farmer so he never covered up the fact
that she had eventually helped the guy
and that was the narrative that got
perpetrated was that he had selectively
edited to make it look like she was just
racist and that and that that she you
know didn't help this guy and that part
of it was all totally manufactured and
he unfortunately for him he had to watch
the narrative just slip away from him
because of that error that they made in
terms of the timing and that happens
when you're fighting against the machine
if you make one mistake one misstep and
they will pounce on it and try and
smother the rest of the story regardless
of what it is any ad hoc apology or
argument so John Lewis Civil Rights icon
and this is this is something race libel
er and he said that you know on his way
into the Capitol someone hurled the
n-word in him at least 15 times by 15
different people
Andre Carson right and you could not
find you you had you show five different
clips from five different angles of the
same moment in time by members of what
are called the army of citizen
journalists right did John Lewis and
Andre Carson ever come out and retract
their claims that that word was thrown
oh no not only that not only have they
not retracted it I think as recently as
about six months ago Andre Carson
repeated it they have not walked away
from it at all and it's absolutely
[ __ ] it's a total race libel anybody
that watches any of the footage that
came out of there can see it absolutely
never had you can't find one example of
being used they said it was chanted it's
a horrifying episode if you're a fan of
the civil rights movement and I'm a fan
of civil rights I mean I think what they
didn't in the fifties and sixties it was
incredibly courageous and brave and was
a good thing for our country and they've
crapped all over that legacy with this
lie and it was I think a very important
point in the documentary in terms of
Andrew Breitbart and Andrew Breitbart
thesis because you know basically what
Andrew Breitbart represents is really
one of the first manifestations of being
able to harness sin as citizen
journalists he was very quick to
recognize that the ubiquity of media the
ubiquity of people's cameras meant that
the mainstream media who used to be the
only people on the scene with a camera
that allowed them to own the narrative
that those days were over and he knew
this from experience because he'd been
to enough things where a narrative was
created about whatever event that he was
at but there was video footage that
showed that that was absolutely not what
happened it was usually from people who
just happened to be in attendance so he
was he was smart enough to know in
today's day of ubiquitous media that if
something happened it was extremely
likely that it would have been
documented and we see that now I mean it
helped law enforcement solve the
Marathon bombing it weren't a
postmodernist age where everyone can
cast their own net and bring in their
side of the story yeah it's it's it's a
very activist median I don't mean
activist in terms of activists for this
cause or that cause it's people average
regular people who are activated because
what they're seeing is whatever niche
topic it is that interests them they're
seeing
there's an injustice being done in the
coverage of whatever it is that's
interesting them I was activated because
I witnessed that in Crawford Texas they
were calling these Cindy Sheehan
protesters grassroots and that they were
living in ditches when in fact they had
a football-field-sized catering tent it
was serving three hot meals a day Cindy
Sheehan was in an air-conditioned
trailer that's not to be the worst of it
they had their own satellite truck
parked right next to the tent where they
were producing their own content and
uploading it that activated me and I'm
I'm just one drop in the bucket people
are all over the country in their own
unique way witness that there's a
disconnect between the reality on the
ground and what gets portrayed and
because they're empowered with their
camera their cell phone whatever they
can cover it themselves and they can
circumvent the narrative and the legacy
because if bright Bart's existence widen
the chasm between new media and old
journalism what is the impact today what
sites do you see what specific examples
where do you see andrew breitbart
influence in new media um well I still
see it at the Breitbart sites they're
still fighting the fight and they carry
on who's in his honor but you see
everywhere look at Michele Malkin's
twitchy okay that's a perfect example
where she you know Twitter Twitter was
for forever was the since this beginning
was the domain of the left and that's
begun to change over time and she really
harnessed that change by creating a
website that aggregates the the tweets
and what it creates as a community of
activated people who then are able to
respond within the ecosystem of Twitter
and she has single-handedly basically
driven the conservative movement
directly into the liberal movement so
like that kind of it's it's bull she
stands up and she and she and she takes
the fight people like Jeremy Siegel
rebel pundit out of Chicago who with his
video camera dressed up like an
anarchist and embedded with the Occupy
movement and was the only person the
only journalist who ran with them and
documented their their vandalism when
the mainstream media was portraying them
as
is you know a wholesome peaceful
protesters he was the you know out there
documenting that that's that the case
and and you know people like Jeremy
Siegel we're absolutely inspired by the
likes of Andrew Breitbart so it's it's
definitely out there it's not pretty you
know individuals will get it wrong
they're not big J journalists you know
so they'll make mistakes it's you know
so that's the but it's I think it's
self-correcting I mean it's a big enough
community and again you brought up the
Boston bombings perfect example people
were upset that it became sort of a
digital lynch mob you know are these
people guilty or these people can't they
but I actually found that to be like the
perfect example of crowdsourcing because
people were wrong about the the
questions they were raising and it was
almost immediately debunked I think
that's the that is the beauty of that ok
and it can be said that you know people
on the right have Fox News and dredge
report people on the Left have MS and
dailykos or New York Times whatever is
that also part of bright parts influence
is that good thing and is that an honest
characterization of how people consume
media hmm I'm not sure I don't know I
think that you know I think that Andrew
had an influence in terms of emboldened
people to strike out on their own and so
I think you see more and more media
that's developed that does that in terms
of on the meta level in terms of
something as big as you know affecting
on the level of the New York Times I
don't know I feel like it's sort of
static I mean I feel like we're sort of
where we were before Breitbart you know
you have the Rush Limbaugh you've got
the Fox News you know conservatives have
won on cable leave one on radio and
they've lost at the ballot box I have
two final questions one you know
conspiracy theories abound that Andrew
Breitbart did not succumb to natural
causes
do you ever give in to those feelings
and entertain those thoughts
tonight when they creep up but usually
creep up in the shower the look I'm of
the position I can't I can't say with
absolute determination what happened but
I can tell you based on what I witnessed
of Andrew Breitbart and of what I
witnessed am Andrew Breitbart as
shocking as it is that he died at 43 of
a heart attack I can believe it you know
the guy not only did burn the candle at
both ends he found new parts of the
candle you didn't know you could burn
and he had had a heart condition a year
prior so it was a condition that was
that was known about you know but I
understand why people wonder about it
it's hard to accept that somebody at 43
years old so active and so filled with
life can suddenly be gone that and the
fact that he had made incredibly
powerful enemies you know I think that
makes that makes people wonder danced on
is great the moment his death was
announced and my final question why
didn't you include his death in Andrew
Breitbart gave us incredible latitude in
the production of this film okay he what
we said to him was you got if you let us
in you got to give us you know carte
blanche access and you can't have
control or gonna do because that would
be then we'd be making your movie
instead of making a film about what
we're making this film about he was
amazing about that so we went through
two and a half three years of production
without him seeing any of it and we then
gave him a screening of the of a rough
cut approximately two months before he
passed away and the guy absolutely fell
in love with the movie he he saw 12
different ways of using it as a weapon
you know and that wasn't our intent but
you know that was a you knew Breitbart
and after he passed there was a lot of
pressure to make it more of a
retrospective to deal with the death
I just felt committed to tell the story
that he saw before dying and make it
about what his fight was and not make it
about his death now you know maybe there
will be a sequel called loving Breitbart
where we where we focus on that you know
and get into his tactic
and the effective is passing and all of
that but it just didn't seem appropriate
for this one this was about the fight
that he was fighting and the movement he
was fighting for and and we present the
death kind of how we experienced it very
suddenly very shocking well andrew
breitbart lives on in your documentary
thank you so much Andrew Marcus
alright well make sure you check in with
reason.com
for future events and you can also check
out hating Breitbart for yourself for
reason TV I'm Kennedy
Oh